das österreichische bundesheer startet
ein neues pilotprojekt zu den rund 450
herres sportlerinnen und heeressportler
kommen jetzt ein paar neue dazu die
sportler wir erwarten uns ehrlich gesagt
von sport sehr fehler und beobachten das
und schauen wo wir hier und auch finden
können und ob wir vielleicht eine dieser
sportarten neu aufnehmen können
der sogenannte e sport ist vom
geheimtipp zu einem massenphänomen
geworden erfüllt ganze stadien hat
eigene fernsehkanäle und
selbstverständlich auch seine eigenen
stars einer von ihnen ist jetzt beim
bundesheer fabio zählt ist die sportler
bei red bull salzburg also ich bin jetzt
zurzeit auch dem 112 den zwölften platz
in europa meine bisherigen erfolge sind
klappt wunderbar sl benfica dann bin ich
der erste gründungs kempe von eintracht
frankfurt und dritter platz im
bundesliga 2009/10 eigentlich schon
richtig große erfolge di fabio f cell
den echten fußball verletzungsbedingt
verwehrt bleiben
als erfolgshungriger sportler weise
allerdings im sportspiel verletzungen
nur bedingt eine rolle und
leistungssport ist es aber trotzdem
es unterscheidet sich halt nicht so viel
wie im echten fußball aber das halt
einfach ein sport ist was macht es tun
die konzentrationsfähigkeit die
schnelligkeit und die flexibilität für
das bundesheer ist die betreuung von
sportlern nur zum teil neuland die
zutaten für große erfolge sind bekannt
wir kennen die gewürze denen die suppe
gehören
die frage ist wie die mischung dann
ausschauen muss damit man das beste
gericht damit erreichen kann und das ist
das ziel des pilotprojekts ein projekt
mit bis jetzt muss unkalkulierbarem
wachstumspotenzial man kann ich vom
mikrokosmos reden weil in österreich
spielen fast fünf millionen menschen
computer und konsolen und handy games
und im sportverband sind über 50.000
spielerinnen registriert das ist eine
ganz schön große gruppe und insofern
glaube ich haben sich hat sich dieser
bevölkerung verdient auch ernst genommen
zu werden und aus ihrem hobby das sie
sehr intensiv betreiben und sehr
professionell betreiben und all die
funktionäre die hier mithelfen
auch entsprechende wertschätzung zu
bekommen der e sport ist schon jetzt der
breitensport unserer zeit werde
erfolgreich sein möchte muss wie in
jeder anderen sportart auch mehr geben
als alle anderen
die rsg sportler sind dafür bereit in
die zukunft blicken und alles was einem
neuen sportarten sich anbietet und
zulauf bekommt das müssen wir mit
beobachten das tun wir und ich bin
überzeugt davon dass wir auch einen
gemeinsamen weg finden werden